at least 200 000 syrian refugees live in
lebanon's capital
the united nations says 16 000 of them
were directly affected by the beirut
port explosion
in august rehab al omar
and her family survived the blast but
their source of income
did not she explains her husband hasn't
been able to find work
in weeks like so many other syrians he
is an informal
laborer my husband lost his job after
the port explosion
he tries his best to find temporary jobs
to be able to feed us
my son is working he earns 60 000
lebanese lyra a week
that's roughly 10 on the black market
exchange
earned by her ten-year-old son mahmoud
who works 12
hours a day helping a tailor the local
currency has sharply devalued
in the past year even before the beirut
blast obviously we have ongoing cash
assistance programs
and those are given in lebanese bounds
but we have increased the amount in
order to
partially compensate for the inflation
it's not enough for many families who
are struggling during lebanon's
financial meltdown
u.n statistics show at least 80 percent
of the 900 000
refugees registered with the agency live
below the poverty line
that is classified as having to survive
on less than three dollars
a day the situation was bad and after
the blast it got worse
if i work i can just buy food not pay
for rent or medicine for my daughter
regular jobs are hard to come by already
there are government imposed
restrictions on the ability of refugees
to work
support from aid organizations is not
enough to stop living conditions
from worsening syrians were affected as
everyone else in the country but
in greater percentage because when
[Music]
when you are an employer the first
persons you will lay off are the syrians
lebanon hosts one of the highest numbers
of refugees per capita
in the world and 50 of its population of
5 million people
are poor many syrians live in this
impoverished
neighborhood next to the port where some
of them used to work
carrentina was among the areas damaged
by the blast
at least 40 syrians were among the 200
people killed
three months on the lack of food and
shelter
is still a concern for many senator al
jazeera beirut